what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on a friday night
boy to [__] pieces so i figured i'd
reach out to my pantry on [__] family
see what's happening smoke a little
number with you
a little led zeppelin since i've been
loving you that's as good as it gets you
know what i'm saying
like a doctor it was a good [__] week
you understand me got some [__] packed
away
we're getting ready to go we got a
couple more podcasts we're gonna let you
on the lurch you know me
uncle joey will never leave you on the
ledge
i'm smoking some tremendous weed from
urban trees i don't know what it is who
gives a [__] i just put them in the
heater and wait for them to dry
and that's it and that's that no big
[__] drama you know what i'm saying
no big spectacle i don't need no you
know nice and easy
we roll a couple numbers we chitchat for
10 minutes
and hopefully i can brighten your day
with a little bit of smile and sunshine
you know what i'm saying like
[__] what are you gonna do you're
gonna walk around wounded for the next
two [__] months
accept it and you're still a bad
[__]
that you accepted it you know i'm saying
i was going to read you a little bedtime
story
but i'm reading this pete rose
my man bob leling is always sending me
the books i want you know what i'm
saying
i don't think pete rose is the perfect
bedtime story you know i'm saying you
don't need to hear about gambling
and [__] betting i love the guy
listen i grew up on pete rose
him and [__] clemente they're up
there in the top five
but the dude [__] gambled on this
team now it was 20 something years ago
me i'd figured big guy
he did what he had to do you know what
you can't take away what he did what are
you going to put an ass
at an asterisk next to it [__] that [__]
am i high [__] you i've been huh my wife
went to bed at night i've been back here
hitting [__] bong hits i got my
[__] babanya
bills my kick them off i've been like
[__] penalties
they got me ready for zoomville and i
did my little tea
two little bags of kicking off t sleep
i'm ready to go i'm just here just to
let you know i didn't forget about you
[__]
uncle joey loves you with all he's got
and you patreon [__] are off
the chain i love you is all
and turn mike king to [__] allison
you people are just [__] great my man
thompson new jersey
i said that's that what do you want from
me you think i'm gonna light myself
on fire it's [__] friday night i'm
just as bored as you are
happy has got [__] insomnia that's
like figured i'd reach out to you now
it's something i haven't signed i can
hit the crib i just refuse
you know i'm saying you're like sit
there and go i'm too [__] old to be
going to bed at 11 o'clock at night i
should be embedded
i ain't got that in me i gotta roll till
about 1 30.
maybe read a couple more chapters i
answered your emails on uh
patreon thank you very much you guys are
[__] been sensational
is what i wanted to create a community
for us i didn't have a lot of time this
week so i'm giving you a [__] video
next week i got a blog that's going to
blow your [__] socks so if you
understand me
you're going to see a different way to
look at comedy
i became a comic and i wanted to become
a comic so bad
that i studied singers
to see how they got the zone [__]
tremendous [__]
but that's how i wrote you know if
you're gonna do something do it
get in there with two [__] hands roll
up your sleeves and cut this [__]
nothing's gonna happen to you if you
don't put on at the same effort
if you're just on dilly dally well
you're gonna get dilly dally [__]
results
uncle joey goes for bro
keeps i got mouse to feed you what i'm
saying
mouths to feed friends to help it's a
bad time
you know you can't think about yourself
you gotta think about what they're doing
put yourself in their shoes
now in a light enough what's happening
you bad [__]
you [__] [__] sucking mother i love
you is all you're all [__] nuts
following your uncle joey your uncle
joey got your back and i'm saying i'm
america's [__] uncle
i'm what everybody needs is a [__]
outfit when you come to think about it
i'm straight with you i'll talk to you
how to [__] shoot [__] i will
[__] do something different
and i [__] make sure you go to school
which is the most important thing you
want to get higher you want to jump up
and down
get that degree be a [__] lawyer
even if you're not a lawyer you've got a
law degree who's better than you who's
going to stop you
do what you want to do please get banned
you'll defend a couple [__] scumbags
like me maybe i'll have a case for you
better you never [__] know
do you remember mama when i knocked upon
your door are you [__] nuts or what
this leads up in a [__] three this is
tremendous
gallows pole this the immigrant song
listen you might as well break out the
syringe and call the chinese guy and
tell them to bring over some china white
mountain white part of my ascension you
know what i'm saying
this joint is tremendous
i'm gonna have a protein shake a couple
of [__] garlic pills to blow these
mine tomorrow
i ain't make forties and i drink a can
poochie
you gotta see the rash comes back and
leave that
i blast one [__] foot even with the
mask on he disintegrates
that's what i do i love that [__] i'm 50
i'm 57 going on eight
if you haven't figured that out yet
you're slipping the only problem between
me and an eight-year-old
i've [__] done things you know hey
listen
sometimes you got to do the wrong things
to get to the right place and here we
are
so [__] it let bygones be bygones
i got 10 more days in this city i did
more
than i'd ever thought i'd do you
understand i'm trying to say that you've
been to that point like
there's no clubs till [__] january
maybe
i'm not getting on a [__] plane i'll
[__] around with you guys here on
uh patreon to [__] san gennaro's day
i don't give a frenchman's [__]
i'm enjoying this it's a little personal
conversation no negativity
no [__] bring it listen we're just
straight up gangsters
i asked for a dollar there was a reason
i wanted a commitment from you so
it makes it easier i know you're all in
you know what you can still pay it down
and insult me i don't give a frenchman's
[__]
but i want this to be a community pretty
soon i'm going to open up more by more
by more by the time we get to september
we'll mid september we'll have a
tremendous podcast put together for you
i got a name for it so far
don't worry about nothing i'm thinking
about you kind of suck if you think i'm
here scratching my nuts sniffing my
fingers
mind [__] myself i'm all in i'm
saying
you've been there you're all lit when
you're all in you're all [__] in
somebody's gonna come in your way and
tell you are you you're not gonna be
able to do this that's why i keep it to
a [__] minimum
i focus on the patreon now i focus on
the twitter
the [__] instagram but i give you
guys a complete different flavor from
the video in the morning
you know that thing in the morning is
powerful you click that little message
on i'm gonna set you [__] straight
i'm gonna put you in the position i used
to put myself
when i was a lazy sack of [__] and all i
was was a thief
i'd wake up in the morning you still
gotta push yourself in the thief
wake up hungry walk a few miles with
nothing in your stomach
maybe you do a little break and you make
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich to
keep you together
let me tell you something the peanut
butter and jelly sandwich is underrated
everybody's waiting for it in my salami
you put together a little peanut butter
and jelly on [__]
white bread you might rethink your
priorities
little ufo strangers
in the [__] night rock
bottom you gotta hear michael shank this
guitar solo on this one what what
what are you nuts [__] oh oh what rock
bottom
rock bottom what
[Music]
i just came to check in with these we'll
make sure i love you i got you back
patreon you're the goods you and i both
know this we're creating a [__]
community
we're gonna have 50 000 people and then
we're making moves
we're taking over [__] islands we
understand we're doing things
[Music]
you know me i'm a [__] idea man so
but i have a couple of bottlenecks in me
tonight absolutely some mechanical
rupees
absolutely but i still make time for you
[__]
to let you know i love you i appreciate
everything you do by being a part of
this
and listen have a great weekend stay
safe
don't get shot because then they're
gonna say you gotta told me so don't get
shot
[Music]
and don't shoot nobody all right uncle
joey loves you right we'll talk on
monday maybe something like that but any
email you got
i'm open to it that's why i'm here so do
not be [__] uh
you know trigger happy don't be sending
me small biographies you know what i'm
saying
i'm part of the speed reading dynamic i
get to it
i get to the meat potatoes and i give
you what you got and listen the answer
is not sugar coated
i'm not blowing smoke up your ass i'm
going to give it to you straight so
there's no misunderstandings all right
[Music]
i think these amateurs don't know this
is the rock right here when you got it
down to this level here
you're hitting [__] atomic fuels you
understand me
oh yeah
[Music]
and that's it that's that i told you i'd
check in with you [__] why
because i love you without you guys
i gotta guess listen have a great
weekend
stay black and you know i love you
[__] all right
i got you we'll be back monday i got a
nice [__] little blog for you to
relate to
and that's it thank you for [__]
catching me late night
i know you [__] across the pond
and jumping up and down the americans
will get this in the morning
have a great weekend i love you
[__] for that
without you i'd have [__] all right
stick around
it's only going to get better trust me